education skills it turns out our
paramount the ability actually
articulate what your idea is in a very
short period of time is number one
number two and this is far in some ways
more complicated to explain it just
because you have a good idea doesn't
make your gonna mean you're gonna make
money there's a difference between a
good idea and someone who can execute
the business plan so you spend the next
five minutes through a presentation
explaining why you're the right person
to actually execute the plan or whether
it's on Dragon's Den Shark Tank or out
somewhere else you have to go through
that gauntlet to prove that you're the
right person or your team are the right
people and if those two things come
together then the magic starts that's
when a team or person starts to sizzle
like an isotope because clearly they
become a leader it's clear that they're
different than everybody else
not only can then articulate their idea
they can actually convince you they can
execute it and they're evil just maniacs
and even when it starts to fail because
of their own inadequacies
they don't stop themselves that's a
typical situation so you can have to
look yourself in the mirror this is hard
to do sometimes and say what am i
greatly good at and what do I suck at
because you don't want to spend any of
your time doing things you're no good
your go-to software company have to make
10 million discs a month you don't like
that you better find a guy who knows how
to do that and you better make it your
partner very early on in the process
and I mean part I mean you give him
something to give equity up to fulfill
the weaknesses in your own portfolio
that is the key to success I have never
made
doing all myself so many businesses now
started many failed at many the only
ones I've really made money on papyrus
where I found people that were good at
things that I wasn't good at I won't
need employees I'd be giving them exit
of the business so that they have the
same risks and desires that I have you
just watch - amazing clips i'm kevin
o'leary you take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]